[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
m
[Musique]
bonjour nouveau numéro de pourvu qu'ça
dure l'émission qui rend les
co-responsables sur public sénat
aujourd'hui émission spéciale sur les
grands enseignements de cette crise
sanitaire et oui jamais l'économie
n'avait été mis sous cloche auparavant
jamais l'état n'était intervenu aussi
massivement pour éviter des millions de
chômeurs jamais les banques centrales
avaient financé des plans d'urgence dans
de telles proportions qui aurait pu
imaginer que tant français se
retrouverait en télétravail qui aurait
pu imaginer que l'immobilier et la
bourse porterait aussi bien aujourd'hui
que l'inflation forêt son grand retour
ou encore que les état déciderait
d'accélérer leur transition énergétique
ce qui paraissait impensable avant la
crise est devenu du jour au lendemain
une réalité alors pour en parler un thé
prestige françois villeroy de galhau le
gouverneur de la banque de france mais
d'abord les chiffres clés de l'impact
cette pandémie sur l'économie française
c'est parti quel impact la pandémie
at-elle sur l'économie française d'abord
la croissance elle s'est effondrée de
8,3 pour cent en 2020 du jamais vu
depuis la seconde guerre mondiale mais
en 2021 l'activité a fortement rebondi
de quasiment 7% quelle est la facture
pour l'état et nos comptes publics le
gouvernement à débourser des dizaines de
milliards pour soutenir l'activité et le
pouvoir d'achat
prise en charge des tests de dépistage
et de la vaccination chômage partiel
aide aux entreprises plan de soutien à
l'aéronautique au tourisme à la culture
ou à l'automobile entre 170 et 200
milliards ont ainsi été dépensés sur
deux ans dp j'ai eu des prêts garantis
par l'état ont aussi permis à sept cent
mille entreprises de ne pas être en
difficulté financière un quoi qu'il en
coûte qui nous a aidé à retrouver fin
2021 notre niveau de prospérité d'avant
crise des handicaps pour l'économie
française désormais depuis le début de
la pandémie notre dette publique s'est
envolé de 450 milliards d'euros pour
approcher le niveau record de 115 points
de pib
enfin l'inflation tourne actuellement
autour de 3% sur un an un niveau inédit
depuis 15 ans est une source
d'inquiétude pour le pouvoir d'achat des
ménages
[Musique]
aller retour sur les grands
enseignements de cette crise sanitaire
sans précédent avec le gouverneur la
banque de france françois villeroy de
galhau bonjour bonjour vie déjà bien
installée vous merci être l'air sur
public sénat
déjà première question peut-être un peu
plus pour le coup personnel est ce que
cette crise a changé ou pas d'ailleurs
un votre rapport à l'économie et ce
qu'elle a amendé fait évoluer certaines
de vos croyances de nos convictions
économiques ou pas du tout
la réponse est sans doute quelque part
entre les deux
peut-être deux sentiments qui me
viennent le premier c'est je crois que
la crise nous amener temps à réagir
beaucoup plus vite je n'oublierai jamais
la première semaine du confinement vous
souvenez en mars 2020 en 48 heures ont
dû basculer tous les hommes et les
femmes de la banque de france en
télétravail et on a dû décider le 18
mars au soir le plus la plus grosse
intervention de l'histoire de l'euro au
téléphone depuis depuis chez nous nos
choix qu'on a agi vite et bien
d'ailleurs et puis peut-être un autre
enseignement c'est une confirmation
c'est que la crise a encore augmenté
l'importance d'être sur le terrain au
plus près de tous les acteurs
économiques dont les entrepreneurs nous
les écoutons énormément par des enquêtes
mensuelles par des rencontres que j'ai
voilà pour qu'ils nous disent comment
ils ont vécu les hauts et les bas de la
crise parce que le moins qu'on puisse
dire c'est que ça a été une période sans
précédent il a fallu évidemment
préserver le niveau de vie des français
éviter des faillites en cascade et donc
on assistait une intervention massive de
l'état pour sauver l'économie d'un
désastre et c'est ce qu'on appelle quoi
qu'il en coûte il est évidemment
nécessaire il ya pas vraiment de débat
là dessus après est ce qu'on en a trop
fait est-ce que l'arrosage a été trop
massif ou est-ce que c'est pas un sujet
je crois que globalement ça a été bien
fait c'est assez rare qu'à gouverneur la
banque de france dit ce qu'il fallait
des déficits beaucoup plus important et
qu'il fallait augmenter la dette
publique c'est ce qui s'est passé en
france et ce qui s'est passé dans la
plupart des pays européens c'est ce qui
s'est passé au niveau de l'europe dans
son ensemble puisque on a décidé une
intervention concertée à un programme
d'investissement de 750 milliards qui
n'avait pas de précédent après on peut
toujours discuter est ce que au milliard
près ce que sur telle ou telle aide on
pouvait faire encore mieux enfin vous
c'est dans l'action il vaut mieux faire
bien que chercher à optimiser à tout
moment crée entre aux règles de la
bureaucratie surtout des retards non
notre problème c'était l'avant qu'ovide
c'est qu'on avait trop de dette publique
dans l'économie française avant le coc
vide et puis une autre question ça va
être la praye coville justement va en
parler en termes de politique économique
est ce qu'on a fait quelque part une
espèce de saut dans l'inconnu parce que
voir le déficit public français financés
par ce qu'on appelle de la création
monétaire dans de telles proportions
pardon mais avant la crise c'était
inimaginable
impensable alors d'aller aussi loin
david jacquot d'asrock faut être précis
et je suis obligé de réagir à ce que
vous dites ce déficit financé par la
création monétaire il ya eu deux
interventions publiques massives ya eu
l'intervention budgétaire il le fallait
pour les raisons qu'on a dit un de
soutien aux entreprises et à travers des
entreprises aux salariés aux français et
puis il ya eu une politique monétaire
très active pour contrer le risque de
déflation si nous avons agi c'est pas
pour financer les états c'est parce que
souvenez vous début 2020 on avait une
inflation qui était déjà trop faible et
on était menacée par cette grave maladie
de l'économique et la déflation et vous
avez 2 vaches ne l'avons pas yaya pas on
pose la question de la planche à billets
il n'y a pas de planche à billets des
recettes interdite par le traité de
maastricht et les statuts de la bce
quand nous achetons de la dette publique
nous l'achetons toujours oui pardon de
cette pression sur le manque toujours
sur le marché secondaire donc il a fallu
avant nous accueillait des investisseurs
privés français ou internationaux qui a
préféré se dit bien dans les comptes de
la bce sur la mappe rached okaya et
archets le cadrede ya une partie sur le
marché de l'occasion comme il dit qui va
temporairement dans le bilan de monsieur
mais cette partie est elle même limité
c'est une minorité de la dette au plus
haut de la crise d'ailleurs j'ai lu que
plus de la moitié de la dette publique
des états européens ont été achetés par
la bce on est mars avril mai 2020 je
crois qu'il faut on va regarder la dette
française par exemple quand vous
regardez l'ensemble de la dette publique
française au sens il y en a entre 20 et
25% qui est détenu petite partie par la
bce la plus grosse partie par la banque
de france il faut reconnaître que sans
l'intervention encore une fois et
l'action des banques centrales notamment
ce plan d'urgence pandémique 1850
milliards d'euros la crise sanitaire ce
serait doublée d'un ko
devenir absolument est dans une crise
économique beaucoup plus grave non je
crois que quand je parlais tout à
l'heure de rapidité d'action c'est ça
qui a été réussie de ce point de vue là
d'ailleurs on a appris des crises
précédentes y compris la crise de 2008
c'est qu'il y avait une crise sanitaire
qui avait la priorité
rappelez-vous le choix qui a été fait
c'est un beau choix de solidarité je
trouve humainement qui est de dire on
prend le risque de quasiment arrêté
l'économie pour sauver des vies et ça a
marché c'est ça le confinement donc il y
avait une crise économique il fallait
éviter que s'ajoute à ça une crise
sociale et une crise financière avec une
perte générale de confiance saissac a
permis l'intervention des actionnaires
voilà c'est dit après c'est quoi qu'il
en coûte il a fonctionné d'un point de
vue économique on a retrouvé notre
niveau de prospérité d'avant crise et au
milieu de l'année 2021 alors la france
là à retrouver loyer le niveau scénario
ville un peu plus tôt que prévu et un
peu plus tôt que ses voisins européens
nous avons eu un fort rebond en août
dernier en août septembre dernier voilà
mais la contrepartie encore une fois dû
quoi qu'il en coûte c'est l'envolée de
cette dette publique française 15 points
de pib en deux ans il ya une question
qui revient souvent parce qu'on est en
campagne présidentielle certains disent
il faut pas la rembourser cette dette
kovy d'otis besse i fall à rembourser
votre position j'imagine de fournir à la
rembourser une dette ça ne peut pas être
annulé
d'abord y est une question de confiance
vie s'il a des traders servent encore
quelques fois en 10 mais c'est différent
pour la banque centrale elle elle
pourrait annuler nous n'avons absolument
pas le droit de le faire ça ce serait
vraiment nu financement monétaire des
déficits donc c'est incompatible avec le
traité de l'euro puis supposons même qui
est une possibilité juridique
ça ne rapporte absolument rien aux
français pour une raison très simple je
veux vous rappeler c'est que la dette
française détenue par la banque de
france et à peu près 700 milliards
d'euros
si on la nu d'un trait pendant une
seconde nous nous sommes collectivement
enrichi de 700 milliards mais ça veut
dire qu'on constate un trou de 700
milliards dans les comptes de la banque
de france et la banque de france elle
appartient à tous les français avouent à
l'ensemble il faudrait jouer il donc
immédiatement on constate une perte de
700 milliards équivalent dans le
patrimoine des français on n'a rien
gagné par contre on a entamé fortement
la confiance dans la monnaie qui est
notre premier trésor et dont nous sommes
les garants donc à vous écouter il faut
vraiment s'inquiéter devant cette
envolée de cette dette publique
française sur deux ans et 450 milliards
d'euros dont 14 x et beaucoup mais quand
on regarde par dont la charge d'intérêts
ce sera un bel service de la tête que ça
coûte tous les ans au budget de l'état
on est au plus bas depuis les années 80
est-ce qu'on n'est pas en train de
dramatiser là alors il s'agit pas de
dramatiser il se juge de regarder les
faits est d'abord je rappelle les
chiffres avant comme vide nous étions
déjà 100 % de dette publique après le
vide nous sommes à 115% et quand on
regarde si on prolonge simplement les
tendances vers le rythme de croissance
le rythme de hausse des dépenses
publiques nous avons eu depuis dix ans
on n'arrivera pas à faire reculer ce
sens 15% les ars et les japonais en 200
points de 100% de ratio dette sur tf1
ils ne sont pas morts les japonais sont
un cas extrêmement particulier avec peu
de croissance avec une démographie qui
recule c'est pas du tout transposable à
la france et à l'europe et donc quand on
si on prolonge simplement et qu'on reste
à 115% je dis clairement aujourd'hui que
ça n'est pas soutenable ce n'est pas
soutenable d'abord parce que les taux
d'intérêt risquent de remonter on va
parler tout à l'heure de l'inflation et
puis on avait des taux d'intérêt
exceptionnellement bas jusqu'à présent
je vais vous citer un chiffre de bitchko
si les taux d'intérêt remontent de 1%
dans les années qui viennent ces
quartiers une ardeur ce qui n'est pas un
scénario extrême en dix ans et près de
40 milliards d'euros à terme
milliards 10,4 milliards d'euros ça peut
paraître abstrait c'est l'ensemble du
budget de la défense nationale
aujourd'hui il neige et il ya eu un
effet très favorable de ces taux très
bas mais il serait irresponsable de
parier l'avenir de la france sur le
maintien de ses taux nazaire et puis il
ya d'autres risques il peut y avoir une
autre crise malheureusement nous vivons
dans un monde très incertain il faudra y
avoir moyen d'y faire face et puis nous
aurons des besoins d'investissements
très important sur le changement
climatique notamment c'est souhaitable
donc on ne peut pas se permettre de
laisser la dette à ce niveau de 115%
parce qu'aujourd'hui elles se financent
à taux zéro mais ça sera pas le cas a
dit à m'intéresser pour ça que je dis
c'est que si ça remonte de 1%
soit c'est un scénario il y à des
scénarios plus fort ça serait très
coûteux donc je crois que l'objectif il
faut que nous donnions dans la durée on
va pas faire ça en un an ou deux mais en
disant c'est de dire il faut d'ici dix
ans ramener la dette publique nettement
sous 100 % du public et ça c'est
possible on va sans doute y venir avec
un peu plus de croissance et moins de
hausse des dépenses un petit mode et des
actifs financiers parce qu'on a cac 40
qui a pris quand même 30 % l'an dernier
les prix de l'immobilier sont en forte
hausse 7% sur un an est ce que c'est
parce que certains experts disent tout
ça c'est un petit peu aussi la faute
entre guillemets de la banque centrale
européenne qu'elle est pour partie
responsables de cette envolée des actifs
financiers au travers de sa politique
monétaire qu'est ce que vous leur
répondez pas ce que ça creuse aussi les
inégalités de patrimoine de beaucoup de
français alors là aussi il faut être
précis et sur cette question il ya les
actifs financiers la bourse et ce grâce
à ça évolue essentiellement en fonction
de l'économie comme aux états unis et en
europe donc comme il ya eu un bon rebond
économique qui a eu un rebond des
bourses sur les actifs immobiliers je
crois qu'ils aient d'abord cela profite
à une part beaucoup plus importante de
la population il ya beaucoup de français
qui sont propriétaires de leur logement
et là les taux d'intérêt peuvent jouer
un rôle mais il ya bien d'autres raisons
il ya une aspiration de plus en plus des
familles à voir leur logement il ya les
phénomènes démographiques compris les
familles recomposées donc on estime que
le besoin de logements en france comme
tous les pays avancés augmente
régulièrement et qu'en face de sa
l'offre ne suis pas tout à fait donc ça
c'est des raisons qui n'appartiennent
pas c'est parfois de la bce s'en est
pris à gagner son site un point de
vigilance qui est très important c'est
de vérifier que dans ce développement
fort du crédit immobilier il n'y ait pas
de risque de surendettement des ménages
et c'est pour ça que nous avons pris
avec le haut conseil de stabilité
financière que j'anime et que bruno
lemaire président nous avons pris des
mesures assez forts pour dire pas de
crédit au delà de 25 ans et pas de
charge de remboursement au delà de 35 %
des revenus vous souvenez peut-être que
ça a été assez critique et je note
qu'aujourd'hui ça se passe bien c'est
accepté par tout le monde et nous avons
concilier le bon financement de
l'immobilier avec l'absence de risque de
surendettement des français est ce que
le risque d'une crise boursière d'une
crise financière est plus élevé
aujourd'hui
par rapport encore une fois la situation
pré crise parce que le monde entier
aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup plus de
dettes partout chez tous les agents
économiques ménages entreprises est un
donc l'instabilité financière elle est
plus forte aujourd'hui rappelez-vous ce
qu'on craignait en mars 2020 c'est une
crise financière qui s'ajoute à la crise
y habiter à la crise économique on
craignait au chic que des banques des
compagnies d'assurances soit très
fragilisée nous n'avons pas eu cela et
ça je crois que c'est une bonne nouvelle
permise en partie par l'action des
autorités monétaires puis les
superviseurs que nous sommes est un
système bancaire et d'assurance solide
maintenant il ya un certain nombre de
risques probablement qui a été reportée
sur le moyen terme il y à l'accumulation
de la dette publique nous en avons parlé
puis il ya certaines valorisations de
certains marchés boursiers qui peuvent
paraître élevés nous suivons ça très
précisément la banque de france vient de
publier des mêmes janvier ce qu'elle
appelle son évaluation des risques
systémiques risque très élevé de 13 nous
avons dit précisément que vous pouvez
regarder cette étude est remarquable en
fait donc vous me permettez diddy
renvoyer c'est qu'il ya moins de risques
à court terme que ce qu'on pouvait
craindre un an ou deux mais qu'à moyen
terme il faut surveiller notamment la
valorisation des marchés boursiers voilà
comment avec eux fait d'ailleurs pour le
coup la bce pour éviter
un potentiel une potentielle explosion
encore une fois une correction sur les
marchés boursiers où sur l'immobilier
quelques faits alors la bce d'avoir une
fois être très clair sur les objectifs
de la bce de la banque de france qui
fait partie de cet euro système notre
premier objectif c'est la stabilité des
prix donc c'est ça la boussole de notre
action les prix incluant les actifs non
repris si elle est pressée les prix à la
consommation l équilibre entre l'offre
et la demande dans l'économie et ça
c'est la définition qu'on maintienne
toutes les banques sont tenues faut
regarder aussi un actif finances alors
nous regardons si un certain nombre
d'effets secondaires par rapport à la
politique monétaire visant la stabilité
des prix nous surveillant les risques
financiers mais il ya une boussole
central je crois que c'est ça qui fait
la force d'ailleurs de l'eurosystème et
et des banques centrales c'est que nous
avons une mission un mandat et c'est ça
qui inspire la confiance dans la monnaie
des européens l'inflation et s'éteint
l'un des héritages de cette crise est
inflation qui revient plus fortement que
ce qui était attendu près de 5% en euros
3 % pour le coup en france est ce que
vous n'avez pas un petit peu sous-estimé
cette poussée d'inflation qui pour nous
pour vous êtes une bosse en cette sortie
de crise fois qu'il faut revenir sur ce
qui s'est passé sur cette botte on l'a
peut-être oublié il ya un an l'inflation
en france et en europe 0,1 et selon la
souvenez-vous tout le monde s'inquiétait
d'une inflation trop basse je n'ai pas
souvenir qui est énormément de voix à
l'époque qui ai dit attention
l'inflation arrive les cours du pétrole
même d'ailleurs étaient en territoire il
ya même eu des guerres du pétrole
négatif au printemps 2020 faute tout ça
était une autre aberration d'ailleurs
alors depuis qu'est ce qu'on voit c'est
qu'à proportion de la force de la
reprise économique il ya des tensions
sur les prix de l'énergie et puis des
difficultés d'approvisionnement sur
certaines matières premières ou les semi
conducteurs donc c'est ça qui donne la
bosse d'inflation
cette bosse a été un peu plus haute est
un peu plus longue que ce qu'on
anticipait encore au printemps dernier
mais encore une fois c'est l
anticipation de tout le monde ce que
nous voyons aujourd'hui comme la plupart
des prévisions c'est que l'inflation
devrait décroître progressivement au
long de cette année parce qu'on va quand
même vers une forme de stabilisation des
cours de l'énergie et puis que les
difficultés d'approvisionnement
devraient diminuer et donc dans notre
prévision centrale l'inflation en france
descendrait redescendrait sous 2% d'ici
la fin de cette année mais je veux
insister sur deux choses parce que cette
question est très importante
la première c'est qu'on revient après
vers quelque chose qui n'est pas le
régime créé comme vide d'inflation trop
faible ou quasi zéro dont je parlais on
revient sans doute vers un nouveau
régime d'inflation plus proche de notre
cible de 2% et la deuxième chose sur
laquelle je voudrais insister c'est que
là je viens de vous dire une prévision
de qualité la meilleure que nous
puissions faire aujourd'hui c'est pas
une certitude aveugle nous avons à tout
moment les yeux grands ouverts sur les
données économiques réels et le dialogue
avec les entrepreneurs et les acteurs
économiques et si l'inflation devait
devenir plus persistantes n'ayez aucun
doute sur notre capacité à rien à
volonté d'agir pour ramener l'inflation
durablement autour de notre objectif de
2% ça c'est une garantie très importante
que je donne aux français que nous
donnons collectivement aux acteurs
européens alors ya un phénomène majeur
qui est un petit peu un des enfants de
cette crise et l'accélération de la
transition énergétique est ce que cette
accélération de la part notamment des
états notamment de la france vous l'a
saluée mais ça vous a surpris parce que
c'est paris pas de lien direct entre la
pandémie non je crois que c'est une
bonne chose il aimait le gel des
craintes qu'on pouvait avoir
initialement etc locaux vides éclipse le
climat je crois qu'au contraire
l'urgence de la transition climatique
est aujourd'hui partagée de plus en plus
est au fond quand je regarde l'ensemble
de l'europe et que je me projette à
presles que vite sur les dix ans qui
viennent nous allons devoir réussir deux
grandes transitions la transition
climatique
vers une économie décarbonée
la transition numérique avec davantage
de digital ça c'est les deux grands
chantiers de l'ensemble des européens
qui a des chantiers plus spécifique à la
france dont nous parlons après le
problème de l'offre de travail et le
problème de dette
deux chantiers et serait la bce ont fait
suffisamment pour lutter justement
contre le réchauffement climatique au
delà de cette prise de conscience qu'on
va bien vite et ce risque est là le jab
essieux et la banque de france il ya
près une grande contribution y compris
dans sur une proposition arrive est la
bce est absolument pionnière à l'échelle
mondiale dans le verdissement de sa
politique monétaire concrètement très
concrètement nous avons décidé en
juillet dernier autour de christine
lagarde lorsqu'on a appelé à l'époque la
revue stratégique de politique monétaire
un programme de verdissement que nous
allons appliquer d'ici 2024 d'ici deux
ans en intégrant le climat dans toutes
nos prévisions économiques c'est un
sacré travail et en intégrant le risque
climatique dans les actifs d'entreprise
que nous achetons ou que nous prenons en
garantie pour les refinancements ce
qu'on attend une technique pour ne plus
les lâcher mais qu'est ce que ça veut
dire c'est que quand on prend des actifs
on en est venu évidemment la valeur
financière mais nous allons aussi en
évaluer le risque climatique ça aussi
c'est un gros travail de méthode mais
nous sommes la première banque centrale
au monde dans les grandes banques
centrales à l'avoir décidée et à le
mettre en oeuvre nous sommes en campagne
présidentielle et après le quoi qu'il en
coûte
les français pourraient croire que les
poches de l'état sont très profondes ou
infini en parlait justement des grands
thèmes économiques de cette campagne a
tort
si les français croyaient que des poches
de l'état sont infinies je crois qu'il
faut revenir sur ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure sur l'as monaco arrivé quasiment
200 milliards d'euros pour financer
encore violette ou du registre il y
avait 200 milliards deux cent milliards
david jacquot il fait des circonstances
absolument exceptionnel que cette crise
que vides on n'avait rien vu de tel
depuis 1945 donc il fallait évidemment
des réponses exceptionnelles mais une
fois sortis de la crise restait sur le
niveau actuel de dette publique ne
serait pas soutenable pour les raisons
que j'évoquais tout à l'heure le risque
de remontée des taux les besoins que
nous allons avoir donc il faut se donner
les moyens sur les dix ans qui viennent
de baisser la dette et c'est possible
pour revenir sous les 100% je crois
d'abord qu'il faut davantage de
croissance on va sans doute en parler
une des vraies difficultés de la france
c'est que notre cross que les
économistes appellent la croissance
potentielle
c'est à dire notre croissance
tendancielle en gros a été divisé par
deux depuis 20 ou 30 ans on est passé de
autour de 2% par an un peu plus de 1%
autres pays européens aussi s'est passé
c'est un problème général de l'europe il
se trouve simplement qu'il ya des pays
européens qui ont mieux réussi
l'allemagne est un certain nombre de
pays d'europe du nord donc il faut qu'on
regarde mais c'est pas du tout des
remèdes idéologique cd solution très
pratique ce que nous pouvons faire en
france qui a marché dans d'autres pays
européens ayant le même modèle social
que nous et puis il ya une dernière
composante qui est très importante c'est
une meilleure maîtrise et une meilleure
efficacité de nos dépenses publiques
c'est exactement dans le débat
s'est rallié aux gens c'est important de
10 mètres jeudi au passage dans le débat
il ya plutôt des propositions dans
l'autre sens il ya beaucoup d'idées de
dépenses supplémentaires de baisses
d'impôts additional aliments il faut le
dire très clairement la france n'a pas
les moyens aujourd'hui de dégrader
davantage ses dépenses publiques parce
que qu'est ce que nous faisons quand
nous consentons des baisses d'impôts
supplémentaires ou des dépenses non
financées nous transmettons la facture à
nos enfants à nos petits enfants et eux
ils vont devoir rembourser la facture
avec des tonneaux rae qui risque d'être
beaucoup moins favorables qu'aujourd'hui
après cette priorité aujourd'hui des
français la priorité des français dans
cette campagne électorale c'est le
pouvoir d'achat ça comptera pose la
question c'est assez clair est ce que
pour vous c'est l'est vraiment la mer
des priorités alors pas seulement là je
crois qu'on arrive sur l'autre grand
défi français on vienne pas et de la
dette publique l'autre grand défi
français si cette question de croissance
potentielle
quand vous regardez les projections de
la banque de france la croissance est
forte en 2021 2022 encore assez bonne en
2023 puisque l effet de rattrapage
qu'ovide mais en 2024 nous descendrions
1,4 pour cent et on retrouverait petit à
petit stand ans autour de 1,1 pour cent
ça ça n'est pas assez et ça touche
directement la question du pouvoir
d'achat
pourquoi parce que depuis des années
nous n'avons pas assez de croissance et
ça ça veut dire quand on veut soutenir
le pouvoir d'achat
on le fait au prix d'une dérive de la
dépense publique et de la dette publique
et c'est un peu artificielle par comment
est ce qu'on fait dans sa partie ciel
pour durablement créer du pouvoir
d'achat sainement pour aussi david
jacquot abaisser le taux de chômage qui
reste plus élevé chez nous à queue en
allemagne comme très bien aujourd'hui en
france alors il a baissé mais beaucoup
de nos voisins on ne sait pas toujours
sont à 5 % de taux de chômage
c'est-à-dire quasiment le plein emploi
nous on est encore entre 7 et 8 on a
encore deux millions quatre cent mille
chômeurs 600000 jeune sané ça n'est pas
acceptable socialement on peut pas se
résigner à ça donc je crois que le sujet
qui est derrière touche à cette
insuffisance de croissance il pose des
problèmes du pouvoir d'achat de la dette
du 16 05 pour sa croissance qui sont en
croissance alors ce que nous disons
c'est qu'il serait souhaitable de gagner
en gros un demi point de croissance tant
cesse le passé de un peu plus de 1 à
quelque chose qui est entre 1,5 et 2 et
que c'est possible alors les
transformations européenne dont vous
parliez tout à l'heure le numérique le
climatiques peuvent apporter en gros un
tiers de ce chemin mais les deux tiers
relève de nous et après tout c'est
plutôt une bonne nouvelle nous avons
notre destin en main et le principal
sujet français sur l'insuffisance de
croissance c'est pas l'insuffisance de
dépenses publiques nous en avons
beaucoup c'est même pas l'insuffisance
d'investissements de cap pital
d'investissement est plutôt plus élevé
en france que chez nos voisins
investissements des entreprises comme
investissement c'est la quantité la
quantité d'offres de travail disponible
pour les employeurs publics comme privés
d'ailleurs et là la comparaison avec
l'allemagne est malheureusement très
éclairante quand on regarde le taux
d'emploi c'est-à-dire la part de la
population qui a un emploi il a monté un
peu en france qui est une bonne nouvelle
mais malheureusement nous avons un écart
très important avec l'allemagne c'est 75
% en allemagne 67% en france mais ça se
fait avec des gens comme vous savez
combien ça fait d'emploi si je rapporte
ça la population française ça fait 3
millions d'emplois qui nous manque merci
françois villeroy de galhau le
gouverneur de la banque de france donc
merci pour cet entretien exclusif
évidemment entretien à voir ou revoir
sur public sénat et en replay évidemment
sur publicsenat.fr rendez vous dans deux
semaines
[Musique]